roe vs wade may be on the chopping block
after oral arguments at the supreme
court and joe biden's team prepares for
more coveted authoritarianism i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
it's time to stand up to big tech
protect your data at expressvpn.com
ben before we get to all the news your
reminder you're spending way too much on
your cell phone bill if you are using
anything other than pure talk because
pure talk has great deals on cell phone
coverage do you think you need one of
the big networks in order to make sure
that your coverage is good well what if
you could use the same towers as one of
the big networks but pay like half the
price and right now do you want to be a
hero for the holidays how about getting
your loved one a brand new iphone that's
right puretalk has iphone 12s starting
at just 479 through the end of the year
and yes they have the 13s as well i
switched to pure talk i'm getting the
same great nationwide 5g coverage as the
big guys and here's the thing you can do
that and the average family will save
over hundred dollars a year just by
switching which is a smart move i would
not tell you to use service that i'm not
happy with make the switch yourself with
pure talk's 30 day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose unlimited talk
tech six gigs of data just 30 bucks a
month and like i said you get that
iphone 12 for just 479 bucks makes a
great christmas gift go to puretalk.com
shop for the plan and phone that's right
for you enter promo code shapiro save an
additional 50 off your very first month
and save on a new phone that is
puretalk.com promo code shapiro pure
talk is simply smarter wireless
disclaimer some restrictions apply see
site for details okay so yesterday was
oral argument time at the supreme court
over a brand new abortion law in
mississippi that bans abortions after 15
weeks of pregnancy which by the way is
still a more lenient law than the laws
of places like france the united states
has some of the most liberal abortion
laws on planet earth so lest anybody
tell you that we are puritanical about
abortion precisely the opposite thanks
to supreme court precedent we are one of
the most liberal countries on planet
earth as far as when a woman is allowed
to kill the baby within her womb along
with her doctors
the the mississippi case
would go further mississippi has sort of
a backup law they say well if you uphold
this 15-week ban then we'd like to go to
six weeks
there are a bunch of issues at play in
the mississippi case in order to
understand them we have to go through
the legal precedent but to understand
why this is such a controversy in the
united states of course you have to
understand the role that abortion plays
in the left pantheon of almost
idolatrous worship of particular
political viewpoints so the idea of the
left is that in order to achieve
complete equality you have to get rid of
the material conditions that could lead
to inequality well that means getting
rid of certain baseline biological
realities this is why the left objects
to things like the notion that for
example men are on average taller than
women heather heing who is the professor
of biology over at evergreen state
college remember she lost her job for
making that controversial contention if
you point out that men and women are
different in any way biologically
speaking this is a problem because it
leads to unequal outcomes if you point
out that women are biologically
different in that they have periods and
then they have children and that this
may constrain some of the choices that
they make particularly having children
in the workforce this is very bad and so
in order to achieve complete equality of
outcome we must get rid of kids we have
to make sure that women have the
opportunity to be just like men
biologically speaking so theoretically
they could do that with birth control
but what if they don't want to do that
with birth control what if they get
pregnant well now we might have to force
them to have a baby and this is the
language that the left likes to use
about the perfectly natural process of
getting pregnant and having a kid
forced birth okay now
in no circumstance in life do you think
of a normal biological process coming to
its fruition as the use of force it
doesn't it doesn't occur in any other
biological process that you can name
right when it comes to eating and then
digesting your food if you say that
somebody is digesting their food you
don't say that they are engaged in
forced digestion right that if you said
you know it's probably not a great idea
for you just to vomit up all your food
every day
that that if you said that to somebody
they wouldn't say well your anti-choice
your aunt you'd say well no the normal
process by which you eat food and digest
it is
that and this is true for every
biological process it is a normal
biological process for when a woman
getting pregnant
before when a woman gets pregnant for
her to bring that child to term that is
the normal biological process is not
just for women it is true for every
female creature in the mammalian species
pregnancy generally leads to childbirth
okay but only according to the left
because the left is anti-biology because
biology stands in way as
an obstacle to equality of outcome for
the left abortion has become a sacrament
it moved from safe legal and rare a
tragic situation that requires a tragic
decision sometimes which was the
language of democrats in the 70s 80s and
90s to abortion is the greatest good it
is the highest good because it is only
things like abortion that allow women to
make the same life decisions as men
for example represent carolyn maloney of
new york she was standing outside the
supreme court yesterday and she says
we're not even a democracy if women
can't have abortions
well uh we are speaking out against any
efforts to roll back roe v wade i i feel
that we're not even in a democracy if
women can't make decisions about their
own bodies
we're not even a democracy if a woman
can't choose to abort her child now
whenever people say this is a pro-choice
position the question becomes for the
vast majority of women who get pregnant
they do not get pregnant through rape or
incest that is a vast vast vast minority
of cases according to the guttmacher
institute which is a very left-leaning
social science and and sexual practices
institute that studies the data on this
stuff they say that well under one
percent of all abortions are because of
things like rape and incest
but that's always used as sort of the
leading edge because it relieves the
obligation
from women who get pregnant not through
rape or incest through irresponsibility
or through choice or in some sort of
circumstance that they they don't
particularly want but was foreseeable
and was not through the use of force
that that those are the cases that the
left wishes to protect because again
they wish to protect
abortion
full stop abortion is a sacrament
abortion must be treasured it must be
prized and it must be celebrated in fact
you're not fully a woman unless you have
had an abortion lena dunham famously
said this a few years ago and and the
left kind of got embarrassed by it
because it was so bizarre and strange
but it was true
she said i feel guilty i haven't had an
abortion i feel like i haven't had the
full experience of womanhood in the
united states if i have not had an
abortion and according to the left this
seems to be sort of the way that they
think about this the hard left they
don't think of abortion as a tragic
choice made by some in order to even
further their own life ambitions which
should be bad enough because you're not
allowed to kill people to further your
life ambitions as a general rule
they don't even think of it that way
they've tended to think of it now as
almost a rite of passage it's it's a
it's taking control of your own biology
to achieve equal outcome with men by
making the same life decisions that men
never have to make because men don't get
pregnant
unless you are a real leftist in which
sometimes men
in which case sometimes men do get
pregnant and also sometimes women are
men and have balls so
it's all self-defeating for the left but
again the the end goal is the same which
is men and women exactly the same all of
us interchangeable widgets and if
biology stands in the way of that then
biology is the enemy this is why
abortion is such a closely fought battle
in the united states at a time when
again birth control is widely available
in fact universally available it is not
difficult to obtain condoms it is not
difficult to obtain birth control pills
all of these are widely available over
the counter
and yet we are still having the same
sort of fraught and and hotly fought
arguments about abortion that we were 40
or 50 years ago
we'll get to what actually went down at
the supreme court in just one moment
first let's talk about an amazing gift
you can do for your family okay so
christmas is coming up it's still
hanukkah right now let me tell you about
an amazing gift so i did this for my
parents i went out into their garage
when they were about to move to florida
with us
went out into their garage and they had
just boxes and boxes of old stuff i'm
talking about like old pictures of the
family i'm talking about vhs tapes that
they used to take with the handheld
camcorder
i'm talking about old film reels of my
parents parents and i took all that
stuff i loaded it up into a legacy box i
sent it to my good friends over at
legacy box and they digitized all of
that sent all of the originals back and
sent my parents a digitized version my
parents were able to give these cds dvds
digitized versions to me to my sisters
so we all have the family memories
preserved forever
so make that happen for your own parents
make it happen for yourself as well
their service could not be easier send
in your legacy box filled with old home
movies and photos they'll get to work
creating a digital collection stored on
thumb drive dvd or the cloud plus with
their cyber week sale you can have
everything preserved at a fraction of
the regular price why use legacy box
well each item is hand digitized by a
team of over 200 train technicians right
here in the united states they've been
trusted by over a million people my
family among them legacy boxes cyber
week sale is here they are giving our
listeners the best deal of the year
visit legacybox.com shapiro for an
incredible 65 off any sized legacy box
that's legacybox.com
shapiro for 65 off do not wait the deal
is not going to last long
legacybox.com
shapiro okay so as i say abortion has
now become a sacrament on the left it is
no longer a case of a tragic choice it's
a sacrament and so you have to wonder
why i became a sacrament and the answer
is because it is a sacrifice to
propitiate the gods of
equal outcome
and this is why you see abortion
activists literally taking abortion
pills outside the supreme court building
as though this is an act of heroism
okay these are these are women who are
standing outside the supreme court i say
women because i assume they're gender
again according to the left maybe these
are men says we are taking abortion
pills forever celebrating
look at the heroism
abortion forever yay getting pregnant
irresponsibly and then killing the
growing life within me yay
by the way here i would like to make a
linguistic
uh linguistic and samantha point that
actually has some relevance it's a point
made by robert george the philosopher
over at princeton a lot of people talk
about potential human life when it comes
to when it comes to the fertilization of
an egg he says no that's a human life
with potential that is a that is a
distinction with a difference
you are talking about human lives with
potential the minute that the egg is
fertilized you have a separate dna
profile you have a secret a separate
human being
and the question of when life begins is
very simple it begins at conception
period end of story there really is
no scientific argument about this there
is no other metric for when life begins
that has any sort of consistent
application to the real world or even to
adults
okay so
all this comes to the supreme court
yesterday and there are oral arguments
over what the standard should be
okay so to understand what the standard
should be you sort of have to understand
the timeline of supreme court cases here
so
leading up to roe vs wade which of
course happens in 1973 there's a whole
line of supreme court cases that are
created from whole cloth by the warren
court
designating a generalized right to
privacy now if you look in the
constitution of the united states of
course there is no right to privacy
there are certain rights against things
like unreasonable search and seizure
there's a specific liberty against
unreasonable search and seizure
and we understand that there is such a
thing as private religious practice that
a generalized notion that privacy is a
good thing is embedded in certain parts
of the constitution but there is no wide
scale right to privacy that can be used
to overcome the presumptions of state
authority in a wide variety of matters
it just doesn't exist which is why
whenever the left talks about you know
the second amendment it doesn't mean
what you think it says it certainly
means a lot more what i think it says
then there is a right to privacy in the
constitution which there absolutely is
not so in 1965 there's a very famous
case called griswold versus connecticut
result versus connecticut is about a
connecticut state law
that says that
that you should not be able to be
prescribed contraceptives
and the the idea was that they wanted to
keep up the birth rate that it was that
it was a sin to use contraceptives from
a certain religious perspective and in
griswold versus connecticut the state
runs up directly against the fact that
such prohibitions have been in place in
the united states for a very long time
now
this has nothing to do and this is a key
distinction we should make when it comes
to the law there's the question of what
you think a good law is and there's a
question of what does the state have
authority to regulate these are two
separate questions
so for example i'm not in favor of state
vaccine mandates with regard to kobe 19.
does the state have the ability under
traditional law to regulate vaccine
mandates the answer is yes
okay so i don't have to greenlight what
the state does in order to understand
that the state has the power to do it in
much the same way i don't have to agree
with your use of free speech to believe
in a generalized right to free speech
so what the left likes to do when it
comes to legal discussions is they'll
take a case like griswold versus
connecticut they'll say what do you want
to do get rid of contraceptives for
married people saying no i actually
think contraceptives for married people
are fine i have no generalized problem
with that but that does not go to the
question as to whether the supreme court
whose job it is to determine whether a
state has acted within its regulatory
authority
can go above and beyond that to simply
act as sort of a legislature determining
what's a good law and what's a bad law
that's not the job of the supreme court
the job of the supreme court is not to
determine whether a law is a good idea
or a bad idea the job of the supreme
court is to determine whether a state
law is in conflict with the constitution
or whether it is not in conflict with
the constitution
the reason i bring this up is because in
2012 this was literally what the
democrats claimed about mitt romney mitt
romney had said there is no right to
privacy in the constitution they said oh
so you must be against contraceptives
for married people
no that's not what he means what he
means is that there is no inherent right
to privacy generally speaking that has
now been applied by the way to a variety
of very public activities like same-sex
marriage as well as abortion
like those have nothing to do with
privacy per se
hey they said well you must be you must
be in favor of the connecticut law if
you think there's no right to privacy in
the constitution now i can be against
the connecticut law and also think there
is no right to privacy in the
constitution okay so griswold versus
connecticut happens in 1965 and under a
doctrine called substantive due process
which i'll explain in just one minute
they guarantee they say there's a right
to privacy so here's the thing
the constitution of the united states
again has very specific provisions that
you have to conflict with in order for a
law to be overruled there is no right to
privacy in the constitution so the court
had to create out of whole cloth a
doctrine by which they can simply strike
down laws they don't like and so they
pick up this bizarre thread in american
constitutional history that has a really
dark and terrible history going all the
way back to the dred scott decision the
dred scott decision which happens in
1856 the red scots decision was a
decision in which the supreme court of
the united states led by judge roger
tawny decides that black people who have
escaped to the north do not have any
sort of citizenship rights under the
constitution of the united states
because black people are not in fact
people under the constitution of the
united states this is the dred scott
decision the worst decision in supreme
court history bar none
okay and the doctrine that they used to
strike down federal law on this question
right and state law on this question
the doctrine they use is something they
call substantive due process the
constitution guarantees that every
person shall not be deprived of life
liberty or property without due process
of law what it means is that the
authorities can simply come to your
house and take your stuff you need to go
through some sort of process you need to
go through some sort of judicial process
now there's only one problem in the dred
scott case there was a process okay and
the process was fulfilled meaning
dred scott was living in a free state
there was no process for slaveholders to
regain dred scott as a piece of property
and thus it was not that they were
deprived of due process they had to
process they just lose right but what
the supreme court says in dred scott is
there's something called substantive due
process and what we mean is there has to
be a substantially fair process not the
process itself something substantially
fair has to happen in order for the law
to be legal now you may notice this has
nothing to do with process
and so substantive due process becomes
the hook the supreme court hangs its hat
on for basically the rest of time in
determining that it can strike things
down whenever the supreme court has no
good excuse for striking down a law they
simply declare thanks to substantive due
process
your rights have been violated and
therefore we're going to strike down a
law
just use substantive due process as
basically a catch-all catch-all phrase
meaning we just want to strike a thing
down okay so the supreme court in 1965
says under substantive due process we
are going to strike down this
connecticut law on contraceptives and we
are going to say that there is a
generalized right to privacy in the
constitution that emerges from
emanations and penumbras
okay now
that's ridiculous there's no generalized
rights to privacy that emerges from
quote-unquote emanations and penumbras
okay all they mean by that is that
in the constitution as i've said you can
see certain rights to privacy like
against
unreasonable search and seizure for
example but that doesn't like emerge
into some full-blown fantasy about a
right to privacy that you can then apply
to completely independent circumstances
that are not unreasonable search and
seizure the supreme court simply
declares itself basically the arbiter of
all that is good and just
and creates a right to privacy out of
whole cloth okay so that is the 1965
case
and it's about whether married couples
are allowed to get contraceptives and
they said yes married couples can get
contraceptives then in 1972 the supreme
court goes further in a case called
eisenstadvi baird okay and in this
particular case the question is whether
unmarried couples whether everyone has a
right to contraceptives now again you
can say that a state has a very strong
state interest in unmarried couples not
getting contraceptives the idea being
that you want to incentivize people to
get married right if you want to have
sex you should get married and that way
if you get pregnant you're going to do
so within the context of marriage the
supreme court says there is no rational
basis for you to ban contraceptives from
unmarried people
now again this is not a question it's
whether you agree with the law or
disagree with the law there's a question
as to whether the founders of the
constitution of the united states were
very much in favor of 17 year olds
screwing without contraceptives right
that's that's really what it's about
whether they meant to protect that right
against the predations of state and
local governments the answer is clearly
not but the supreme court has now
extended the right to privacy to you
going down to the pharmacy as a single
person and picking up contraceptives so
you can see how it's growing okay then
they extend it in 1973 to roe versus
wade
we'll get to the case law of reverse
wave in one second which is just crappy
case law it makes no sense whatsoever it
is just creation out of whole cloth now
we've extended from contraceptives which
again might be a certain privacy issue
maybe you can kind of see it through a
glass right because obviously you're
gonna use contraceptives under private
circumstances to now enact abortion
which is very not private because it
involves another human being namely the
child in the womb we'll get to that in
one second first let's talk about your
sleep quality so the holiday season is
exhausting we all need our sleep but
some of us are just tossing and turning
a lot at night i know why you're tossing
and turning it's because you didn't
listen to me you didn't get your helix
sleep mattress yet you should by the way
makes a fantastic present helix sleep
has a quiz it takes just two minutes to
complete it matches your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else with
helix you're getting a mattress you know
will be perfect for the way you sleep
everybody is unique helix knows that so
they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot mattress is great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains even a helix plus size mattress
for plus size sleepers so if you're
looking for a mattress you take the quiz
you order the mattress you match to the
mattress comes directly to your doorship
for free you don't ever need to go to a
mattress store again
they have a 10-year warranty you get to
try it out for 100 nights risk free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you will helix has
financing options as well flexible
payment plans a great night's sleep is
never far away i took the helix lip quiz
my wife and i got a firm mattress that
is very breathable let me tell you we
need it because our kids wake us up at
all hours so we need our sleep helix
sleep makes it happen for us they can do
the same for you go to helixsleep.com
take their two minutes sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
ben okay so we are now up to roe versus
wade 1973.
so in this case the supreme court
invalidates a law from texas that
prohibits all but life-saving abortions
now let's be clear about this before roe
versus wade abortion was not illegal
across the country states like
california had very liberal abortion
laws before roe versus wade
states like new york and more liberal
abortion laws before roe versus wade
before roe vs wade there was a state
standard because again regulatory
standards states have a lot of power to
legislate they have a lot of power to
regulate in these particular areas so
texas law did not look like new york law
so
the the question of roe vs wade is
whether texas had the ability to
regulate abortion and roe vs wade the
court under harry blackman
high on his own fumes says no there is
no ability for states to regulate
abortion because under a vague right to
privacy you now have the ability to kill
your own child
with the help of a doctor this is this
is a right under the constitution of the
united states
they say that the constitutional right
to privacy which again started with the
emanations and penumbras of griswold
versus connecticut nowhere to be found
in the constitutional text encompasses a
woman's right to terminate her pregnancy
the court then characterized this right
as fundamental okay so there are certain
rights that are weighed and balanced
against state interests but they
characterize this as a fundamental right
meaning that the state better have a an
extraordinary interest in order to
regulate abortion in any way
they said the state could not interfere
with abortion unless they had a
compelling reason for regulation
and you could only assert a compelling
interest in protecting a fetus once it
became viable
namely in the last trimester now i
challenge you to find anywhere in the
structure or text of the constitution
a notion that abortion
is
per se
allowed in fact it is guaranteed by the
constitution of the united states
written in 1789
it is it is mandatory that states allow
you to abort your fetus
up until
the uh up until the last trimester which
by the way is like super well developed
you're talking about at that point the
seventh month of pregnancy essentially
okay so that there is no basis for this
whatsoever and by the way the court
doesn't even pretend that there's a
basis for this that's the part that's
truly amazing when you actually read the
court opinion again written by harry
blackman in this case he doesn't even
bother to pretend that he knows what the
hell he is talking about
right the the court says itself in roe
versus way quote the constitution does
not explicitly mention any right to
privacy in a line of decisions however
going back to perhaps as far as union
pacific railroad versus boxford in 1891
the court has recognized a right of
personal privacy or a guarantee of
certain areas or zones of privacy does
exist under the constitution in varying
contexts the court or individual
justices or individual justice and
descent who cares have indeed found at
least the roots of that right in the
first amendment in the fourth and fifth
amendment
in the penumbras of the bill of rights
that's griswold or in the concept of
liberty guaranteed by the first section
of the 14th amendment these decisions
make it clear that only personal rights
that can be deemed fundamental or
implicit in the concept of order liberty
are included in this guarantee of
personal privacy
and they say this right of privacy
whether it be founded in the 14th
amendment's concept of personal liberty
and restrictions upon state action as we
feel it is or as the district court
determined in the ninth amendment's
reservation of rights to the people is
broad enough to encompass a woman's
decision whether or not to terminate her
pregnancy the detriment the state would
impose upon the pregnant woman by
denying this choice altogether is
apparent
okay so again they basically say they
throw up their hands like we have no
clue where this is coming from the
constitution but whether we find it here
or whether we find it here whether we
pull this rabbit out of this hat here or
whether we make the coin appear behind
your ear you have a right to an abortion
under the constitution of the united
states roe vs wade is a joke of a
decision everyone even pro-abortion
people who are legally knowledgeable
understand roe versus weight is legal
garbage they just like the outcome
okay so that is the governing standard
all the way up until planned parenthood
versus casey we'll get to that standard
which is the current governing standard
and abortion law in just one second
first
did you know that garages are the most
frequently accessed entry to the home
it's often overlooked the garage is
where people most important to you come
and go i know that in our house we tend
to use the garage as our thoroughfare so
it makes a lot of sense to know what is
going on there introducing the myq smart
camera by chamberlain it's the only
smart camera optimized for the garage
brought to you by the leaders in garage
door opener technology
they got features like live video
streaming recording events motion
detection two-way communication right
from your phone you can make sure your
garage is secure 24 7.
you know how many times before we had my
q smart camera we'll leave that garage
open yeah unfortunately too much pair it
with the myq smart garage control you'll
never have to worry if you left the
garage door open you can check it see it
close it all from the my q app from
anywhere which means you can open and
close your garage from your phone
there's nothing worse by the way than
getting a call from a friend saying you
left your garage open what do you want
me to do
it's pretty great to be able to just do
it yourself remotely the my cue camera
is easy to install you can quickly
connect it to your phone via bluetooth
in the myq app so what are you waiting
for give the gift of a miq smart garage
camera to your favorite tech lovers this
holiday season if you act right now you
can save 46 for a limited time by
entering ben at checkout on myq dot com
slash ben that was ben at checkout on
myq dot com slash ben to save 46 keep an
eye on what's happening in and around
your home's busiest entryway with the
myq smart garage camera it's the only
smart camera optimized for the garage
okay so
now we get finally to the governing law
as of now plan planned parenthood versus
casey okay so planned parenthood versus
casey you have to fast forward
all the way to 1992.
okay this case is a disaster of a case
when i say it's a disaster for a case i
mean it makes no sense i mean that the
case itself is split one thousand
different ways
okay the the there were three justices
who voted for
parts one two three
va vis
sorry five a five c and six
okay there are another there's another
justice who joined with respect to
parts
five e
and an opinion with respect to parts
four five b and five 5d
and then they open their decision with
this line liberty finds no refuge in a
jurisprudence of doubt okay there's only
one problem you split the decision 1000
different ways in planned parenthood
versus casey
the actual emerging governing law is
actually quite unclear under casey it
makes no sense at all so the case was
expected to go the wrong way it was a
case where conservatives widely expected
that it was going to be overturned
because there had been some new justices
who'd been appointed by republicans who
joined the court justice o'connor
justice kennedy who turned out to be
both of whom turned out to be uh
half-assed guy kind of garbage justices
neither of them were very good
they voted for and kennedy largely wrote
the decision in planned parenthood
versus casey the governing standard
moves from
essentially no regulation of abortion in
the last trimester
to the undue burden test under which
state regulations could survive
constitutional review so long as they
don't place a substantial obstacle in
the path of a woman seeking an abortion
of a non-viable fetus
okay so now the line is no longer last
trimester now the line is viability
okay so you're allowed to regulate
the the abortion of of viable fetuses
but you still have to show a compelling
state interest it's you can sort of
carve back road just a little bit so
planned parenthood cars back road just a
little bit now the planned parenthood
versus casey decision also ends up being
the source of an entire line of cases
that move toward the legalization of
same-sex not legalization forced
legalization at the federal level of
same-sex marriage right that used to be
a state issue also right you'd have
states like california that would
legalize same-sex marriage or
massachusetts then you have cases you'd
have states like alabama or florida that
didn't
okay and then the court just decided to
take that up to the federal level
because this is what they do in usurping
power becoming a group of of
powerful people in robes simply making
law out of their heads as opposed to
interpreting the constitution of the
united states planned parenthood versus
casey sets very bizarre legal standards
that are not legal standards at all
in fact planned parenthood versus casey
contains
literally my least favorite
constitutional line of all time written
by justice anthony kennedy it makes no
sense at all
here's what they say our law affords
constitutional protection to personal
decisions relating to marriage
procreation contraception family
relationships child rearing and
education
our cases recognize the right of the
individual married or signal single to
be free from unwarranted governmental
intrusion into matters so fundamentally
affecting a person as the decision
whether to bear or be get a child right
that was in eisenstadt versus baird
right
that was a predecessor case as we
mentioned two row versus wades they'd
already made way for roe versus wade in
1972. now again there is no history to
suggest that this liberty is as
broad-based as
it is being made here and once they say
you have the liberty as to how you marry
you're basically making the case for
obergefell right all the way up to
same-sex marriage once you say you have
the liberty as to whether or not to to
have a child even post getting pregnant
now you're talking about the case for
abortion all this created by whole cloth
out of a supreme court that has no
relationship to the constitutional tax
in fact by the way justice sonia
sotomayor we'll get to this what the
actual legal arguments looked like in
court yesterday because the supreme
court justices did their questioning
justice sotomayor openly said she was
asked like there's no right to privacy
in the constitution she goes there's
lots of stuff that isn't in the
constitution that we pretend is there
she basically just said it straight out
which by the way is why the supreme
court has been kind of a garbage
institution for quite a while
in any case
the finding in planned parenthood versus
casey the worst constitutional line i
think in modern american history quote
and led by justice kennedy whose entire
theory of constitutional jurisprudence
is that there is a right to autonomy
created by anthony kennedy out of
folkloth and then placed into the
constitution now again there are spheres
of autonomy under the constitution of
the united states because the powers of
the federal government are restricted
under the constitution to make room for
your personal autonomy and state
constitutions do the same thing but
there is no broad-based right to do
whatever you want under the constitution
of the united states that doesn't exist
it has never existed in any land at any
time with any government ever
the the complete right to personal
autonomy to do whatever you want just
does not exist that's not a real thing
again there are spheres of autonomy
there are spheres of choice there are
rights but those rights are are somewhat
circumscribed in the face of for example
moral needs or communal needs it sort of
depends on which level of government
you're talking about which is why local
governments have a lot of power state
governments have fewer powers federal
government is supposed to have the
fewest powers of all so using the
federal government to trump local
governments in the name of rights that
are never established in the federal
constitution is a complete
dereliction and malfeasance when it
comes to the constitutional structure
and the philosophy of the constitution
here's the line that i'm talking about i
keep pitching it because it's so bad
here's what anthony kennedy wrote these
matters involving the most intimate and
personal choices a person may make in a
lifetime choice is central to personal
dignity and autonomy are central to the
liberty protected by the 14th amendment
at the heart of liberty is the right to
define one owns one's own concept of
existence of meaning of the universe of
the mystery of human life beliefs about
these matters could not define the
attributes of personhood were they
formed under compulsion of the state
okay well so basically either you're
advocating for anarchy which is not what
anthony kennedy is doing or you're using
vague mumbo-jumbo philosophical crap in
order to trump basic questions about the
rights that for example unborn human
beings hold
and whether you have the ability to kill
an unborn child in the womb
the the the idea that at the heart of
liberty is the right to define your own
concept of existence of meaning of the
universe of the mystery of human life
uh you're gonna need some sort of
limiting principle there because it
turns out that if you're just saying
that in your head you can define all
those things of course that's true if
you're saying that that now manifests in
action that affects the rest of the
world
nope
then some limits are going to have to be
drawn
particularly when you're waving your
fist around and it hits a baby and kills
the baby at that point you're gonna have
to start drawing some limits okay so
planned parenthood versus casey sets the
the modern standard for undue burden and
the idea is under the under burden
standard the only way that you can
survive a constitutional review
is if you don't place a substantial
obstacle in the path of a woman seeking
an abortion of a non-viable fetus so in
other words the state has a little bit
more authority to regulate abortion post
viability again post viability is
defined in law under planned parenthood
versus casey at like 21 22 weeks that is
super duper late and why its place of
viability is beyond reason like there's
no reason why for example a 19 week old
fetus does not have any protections
but a 21 week old fetus has many many
more protections
viability is a very bad place to draw a
line particularly because medical
viability keeps getting earlier and
earlier and earlier alrighty so
yesterday in the supreme court this
mississippi law comes up
and the question is whether the
mississippi law which bans abortion
after 15 weeks of pregnancy is
unconstitutional
so there are a few things the court can
do here the best thing the court could
do is just overturn roe there's no
constitutional right to an abortion have
had it the states get to decide
what they think the regulations ought to
be that doesn't mean abortion disappears
in california you'll still be able to
abort probably up until the time the
child is four or five
in new york same deal and then they'll
light up the empire state building pink
in celebration of infanticide in in
if governor ralph northam has his way in
in virginia before he leaves office then
um you'll still be able to keep the baby
comfortable while you decide what to do
okay so it's going to vary state by
state if roe versus weight has gotten
rid of and this is why it's always been
a ridiculous contention by the left that
if you get rid of roe v wade abortion
completely disappears if only my your
mouth to god's yours but no that's not
the way that this works okay so
that would be choice number one door
number one then you have door number two
door number two is the overruling of
planned parenthood versus casey
which would get rid of the viability
standard so the idea would be because
the mississippi law goes to 15 weeks the
mississippi law
would now
say okay it's not about the viability
standard
it would have to be some other standard
you'd say that there's still a right to
an abortion but viability is not the
point at which the debate begins and
that opens up a whole can of worms
because then the question becomes okay
so what standard do you draw for when
you're not allowed to abort anymore is
it heartbeat
is it conception right how far back in
the timeline can you push this thing
okay and then you have the the final
possibility here which is that the
supreme court just strikes down the
mississippi law now it's pretty clear at
this point that they're not going to
strike down the mississippi law from the
oral arguments it's clear
the the only people who are arguing at
this point not to strike down that the
mississippi law should be completely
struck down are the three justices on
the left okay the justices on the
supreme court right now they break down
essentially
into three groups of three okay this is
the way that people tend to think of the
supreme court right now so you've got
the the sort of hardcore
constitutionalist that would be clarence
thomas and samuel alito and to a certain
extent
justice gorsuch although obviously his
decision in the in the
extension of the civil rights act to to
transgenderism is insane and
unjustifiable and crazy on every level
but those are the three most
conservative members of the court would
be gorsuch alito and and thomas
and then you have the sort of center of
the court and that right now is
perceived as justice roberts and brett
kavanaugh and amy coney barrett we have
no idea really where amy coney barrett
is but she was specifically appointed on
this point right the reason that trump
picked her is because of roe versus wade
it's because she's written critically of
roe vs wade in the past clearly okay so
that's sort of the center of the court
and then you have the far left of the
court the from from sort of censored to
left it goes elena kagan
stephen breyer and then finally sonia
sotomayor who is just a judicial
activist of the highest degree she's an
abortion activist and she made that
perfectly clear yesterday she was like
in oral arguments she's like yep it's
made up out of cloth we get to make it
up as much as we want to and do you
really want to harm women this way is
this really don't don't you see women
need abortions and so she's not a lawyer
at all she's she's like a justice
ginsburg type who's an activist who's
been put on the court to pretend that
she gives a crap about the law but
actually doesn't you make no mistake
ruth bader ginsburg was a disaster of
justice she was a terrible justice
there are a few administrative law
issues where she was actually not bad
and then on social issues just
she never broke with with now basically
where she used to be a lawyer so that
that is not a that is not a shock sonya
says to miller is much the same way okay
so that's the way the supreme court
divides right three three and three
typically in this particular case it's a
little bit mixed up so you have some
people who clearly want to overrule row
alito and thomas clearly won over roll
row
gorsuch seems to want to overrule roe as
well
and then you have kavanaugh and barrett
and
roberts roberts's entire schtick is that
he doesn't want to undermine the
institutional legitimacy of the court i
don't know what the hell that means the
institutional legitimacy of the court to
me rests on the same institutional
legitimacy as every area of government
are you acting within your purview are
you doing what your job is designated to
do
if you on the supreme court strike down
a law that is in conflict with the
constitution you have done your job if
you do not strike down a law that is in
conflict with the constitution you have
not done your job if you uphold a law
that that is in conflict with the
constitution you've done something wrong
right you have a job to me every area of
legitimacy in life period is about you
doing your job
if you call a plumber and your plumber
comes over and bashes a hole in your
wall
and doesn't fix your plumbing
he has lost his institutional legitimacy
but justice roberts seems to think that
the institutional legitimacy of the
court rests on public polling and this
is why he upheld obamacare the idea was
well if we do something too offensive if
we move too fast we'll lose our
institutional legitimacy
nope you lose your institutional
legitimacy every time you hold a plushy
versus ferguson or a roe versus wade
okay so there was a there's a question
as far as the there are really only a
couple of arguments that the left is
attempting to use with regard to row one
is just an openly political argument we
love abortion please don't get rid of
abortion in texas okay and then there's
argument number two which is starry
decisions starter decisis is the the
basic meaning is the case has been
decided the idea being that if there was
a case with the same fact pattern and in
that case you held one way you shouldn't
hold differently now because it upsets
the apple cart because too many people
have reliance interest people are
reliant on that case and and they retain
a certain reliance culturally on that
case and so you can't overturn it that's
a horrible argument if that argument had
been applied to plessy versus ferguson
we'd still have segregated buses in the
united states
okay so the the or at least
it wouldn't have been ruled illegal by
the supreme court in uh in brown versus
board my brown versus board overturned
plessy versus ferguson
[Music]
and um and
if it had not been for getting rid of
sorry decisions and that like the court
is very unclear about when they are
going to abide by star decisis
obergefell is a complete overruling of
sorry decisis that was already decided
in a case called bowers v hardwick in
1988 and the supreme court took the
exact same fact pattern and found the
exact reverse
so sorry decisis is basically a way for
justices to pick and choose
what they think is worth upholding
without actually having to justify why
they uphold it so you had sonia
sotomayor who does not give any craps
about starry decisions when it comes to
gay marriage for example saying oh
starter decisions really matters here it
really matters an awful lot and justice
thomas who's perfectly consistent about
this is like star decisis is garbage and
we shouldn't pay attention to bad cases
okay so justice roberts
kind of seems to want to chart a middle
path here the middle path being not
overruling either casey or row
instead basically arguing that we will
continue to hold the undue burden
standard but we will move it back to 15
weeks for example or 14 weeks
we won't make it fetal viability per se
we'll just say that something quasi-like
fetal viability moves a little bit
earlier so we'll retain planned
parenthood versus casey and we'll just
say that that it's not about viability
anymore viability keeps getting earlier
we'll set the standard a little bit
earlier there doesn't seem to be the
taste for that from anyone else on the
court
we'll get to more of this analysis in
just one second first obviously
inflation continues to dominate the
country
and we are at a level we have not seen
in decades the cost of everything is
going up you need to be pragmatic
protective and prepared if you're a
homeowner you should be considering a
mortgage refinance right now before
those historically low mortgage rates
are gone
the impact they can make on your budget
is substantial and the people to help
are the folks over at american financing
will get a free no pressure mortgage
review you can learn about custom loans
that fit your life better from lower
rates to shorter terms even high
interest consolidation they can do it
all they are currently saving customers
up to a thousand bucks a month helping
many skip two mortgage payments why not
see what they can do for you now eight
six six seven two one thirty three
hundred that is eight six six 721 3300
or visit
americanfinancing.net you may have
noticed the fed is already talking about
tapering and now accelerating the
tapering what that means is that
mortgage rates are likely to go up in
the in the near to mid future and that
means that now is like the best time
ever to refi because once those mortgage
rates goes up who wants to refund what's
the point head on over to
americanfinancing.net tile 866 721 3300
to get started nmls 182 334 nmls
consumeraccess.org
right we'll get to more analysis of
what's going to happen at the supreme
court that case is likely to be decided
by june
first the daily wire we've been hard at
work keeping our promise we promised you
we're going to bring you tons of new
content you won't get anywhere else and
that you're going to be excited about so
we said we're getting into the movie
business we are we brought out a movie
last year now we have a brand new movie
that is ready it's ready to go our first
original daily wire production shut-in
it's a seat gripping thriller that will
be available to stream early 2022. the
film is super intense here is what that
trailer sounds like
laney
[Music]
[Applause]
where have you been
baby
i'm gonna take off tonight so the kids
can sleep most of the way
well i'm mostly done i just need to
finish cleaning out the pantry
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
please let me out please
lady
[Music]
your daughter she's very pretty don't
you touch my kids
rob owes me money there's money there's
a lot of money there's thousands of
dollars in the pantry have it all
[Music]
please come on i'm scared
it's a really really intense film man
it's a
it's a real movie and that's what we do
here at daily wear it has some values
that you're going to love it is a
terrifying thriller so if you're
planning on adding that terrifying
thriller to your cue in 2022
and you want us to keep making content
to combat the over politicized
mainstream entertaining streaming on
major platforms go like and share the
trailer on youtube really your support
makes a huge difference also
we're getting involved in culture in
pretty much every conceivable way we all
knew that matt walsh had more talent
than he was letting on because he had to
right but none of us knew just how much
talent he actually had he's basically
the new mr rogers he he just sold out of
his new book johnny the walrus
immediately after his release like it
sold out went all the way to the top of
the amazon charts and then it was gone
but don't worry you can reserve your
copy at johnnythewalrus.com get your
hands on the next batch shipping out
soon johnny the walrus it's an inspiring
tale of a young boy who pretends he's
walrus and it's all pretend until the
internet tells johnny's mommy that
johnny is actually a walrus and she must
uphold and she must forward his trans
walrus identity if you know matt's brain
his twisted brain you will laugh your
butt off reading this to your kids or
mostly to yourself and to your liberal
family members head on over to
johnnythewalrus.com reserve your copy of
matt's timely masterpiece johnny the
walrus today you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so you've got the court and
it's split 333 usually in this case not
so much you have three justices who
clearly won over rule row
from the oral arguments it seems that
would be gorsuch and you know elito and
thomas won an overworld row thomas by
the way continues to be the most
underrated justice in american history
thomas is a wonderful wonderful justice
his decisions are really well written
and he's more ideologically consistent
than the uh far more admired antonin
scalia i'm a huge thomas fan okay so you
got three and now you need to get five
if you want to overrule row you're not
gonna get to five with with robert
robertson over ruling row roberts
basically wants to keep the undue burden
standard which is a vague unworkable
standard complete like it makes no sense
the plan parenthood versus casey
standard but get rid of viability and
just move it back to 15 weeks so he kept
saying over and over the thing that is
at issue before us today is 15 weeks and
see council he wants to maintain the
quote-unquote institutional credibility
now there is no justice in my lifetime
who has undermined the institutional
credibility of the supreme court quite
like justice roberts who has now
presided over
obergefell his pr he voted the other way
but he presided his court did overall
burst fell presided over the obamacare
cases
and has presided over a wide variety of
cases that should
both stock like he's presided over a
bunch of cases that are just ruled
either the wrong way or that he overtly
attempted to twist constitutional law in
order to prevent the supreme court from
being embroiled in controversy and in
the process made the supreme court more
embroiled in controversy so justice
roberts wants to not get rid of roe not
get rid of planned parenthood versus
casey just sort of get rid of the
viability standard and move it back
there doesn't seem to be taste for this
the the plaintiffs in this case the the
pro-abortion side
they said in order for you to uphold the
mississippi law you have to get rid of
planned parenthood versus casey they
said there is no way that you uphold the
undue burden standard just move it back
to 15 weeks because once you get rid of
viability then the question becomes what
is your standard of when an abortion is
allowed and when it is not there is no
clear line anymore right ro
is a deeply wrong and i think evil
decision but roe does draw a pretty
clear line on a legal level which is the
last trimester and then planned
parenthood versus casey is a deeply
wrong and stupid decision but it draws
some line and viability if you get rid
of the viability line what's the
standard so even the plaintiffs are like
you have to overrule planned parenthood
versus casey they're trying to leverage
the the
the
court into upholding planned parenthood
versus casey and retaining the viability
standard which is not going to happen
here so the real question here is
kavanaugh and coney barrett those are
the two questions here kavanaugh and
coney bear is what which they choose to
do do they go along with the sort of
narrow decision of justice roberts
or do they say okay we're getting rid of
the viability standard completely and
the under burden standard and we will go
back to the idea that there is a
baseline right to abortion in row
and we will just draw a different
standard as to how to balance those
interests or did they just overrule roe
entirely
justice roberts again trying to draw
that narrow line there was not a lot of
support for it julie reichelman who's a
lawyer for the abortion clinic she
disputed that she said there are limits
in many other countries that are subject
to significant exceptions other
conservative justices this according to
the new york times indicated they were
not interested in roberts's intermediate
approach samuel alito so the only real
options we have are to reaffirm row or
to overrule it which of course i agree
with it
so roberts would need to get two votes
for a narrower opinion
kavanaugh and coney barrett were pretty
silent on all of this they kind of kept
their cards close to their chest on
where they they are on this particular
decision i think the most likely
scenario here is that
he does craft some sort of majority
decision with six votes to pair back
planned parenthood versus casey beyond
the quote unquote viability standard i
think that probably roberts gets his way
here and the reason i say that is
because i just don't think that
kavanaugh and coney barrett have the
stones to actually overturn roe that's
the real question
because it is clear on a legal level
that they should
we've described the entire line of cases
if roe were overturned
20 states would seek to probably make
abortion illegal which leaves last i
checked another 30 states that will not
chief justice roberts expressed
frustration with mississippi's
litigation strategy
in the state's petition seeking supreme
court review officials told the justices
the questions presented do not require
the court to overturn roe or casey
once the court agreed to hear the case
the state shifted its emphasis and began
a sustained assault on these precedents
says the new york times that's not
really true what actually happened is
that mississippi said you don't have to
change planned parenthood versus casey
just say that viability begins earlier
right uphold planned parenthood versus
casey it was the plaintiffs we said you
have to overrule planned parenthood
versus you have to throw the baby out
with bath water it's either all or
nothing and at that point the the
defense the state of mississippi they're
like
okay you want to do all or nothing let's
do all or nothing let's play this game
meanwhile he had justice breyer quoting
from planned parenthood versus casey
[Music]
and he said to overrule under fire in
the absence of the most compelling
reason to re-examine a watershed
decision would subvert the court's
legitimacy beyond any serious question
i'm sorry roe versus wade already
subverted the court's legitimacy
justice sotomayor who is the most
political justice of my lifetime asked
whether the court would quote survive
the stench of being considered a
political institution the stench of
being
sorry guys a little late for that one
considering that you declared that
same-sex marriage was the entire law of
the united states by yourselves without
any constitutional precedent again we
have now declared in the past 10 years
that there is a fundamental right for
men to marry each other under the
constitution of the united states and in
and there's a constitutional right
under the civil rights act as extended
by the civil rights act for men who
believe they are women to be treated
like women in public settings
this is what we have determined and you
think that your constitutional
legitimacy is in question right now i'm
sorry to break it to you your
constitutional legitimacy as a as an
institution has been well in question
since dred scott
it's been about 160 years since you
weren't in question how about do the
right thing constitutionally speaking
okay meanwhile
in other news omicron has now hit the
united states there's been one case
detected in california which means i
guess we have to have a travel ban from
california
sorry guys
in a white house news briefing dr
anthony fauci the greatest of all
doctors except for the the much belly
hood jill biden
he announced that uh it was one person
who traveled from south africa on
november 22nd and tested positive for
covet 19 on november 29th that person is
self-quarantining close contacts have
tested negative
the person was fully vaxxed and is
experiencing mild symptoms which are
improving at this point again i remind
you there is no evidence that omicron is
more deadly than delta in fact there's
some evidence that omicron is less
deadly than delta
but according to anthony fauci even if
you believe that omicron is less deadly
than delta you shouldn't be sanguine
so he was asked a simple question was
was dr anthony fauci okay and the
question was asked by a reporter let's
say that omicron is more transmissible
but less deadly than delta
wouldn't it be good for people to get
omicron as opposed to delta
wouldn't that be better because then
like you assume that everybody's gonna
get delta as i've said before there is
no world in which people just live
completely virus free for the rest of
time it's like the flu is like the
common cold you're gonna get it you're
gonna get immunity through natural
processes or you're gonna get immunity
through the vacs so if you now have to
choose between getting one of these two
variants delta
or or oh
macron if it turns out that omicron is
less deadly than delta wouldn't you
rather have omicron so the reporter
asked voucher that he's like no never no
one must never get this disease no one
so they just keep baiting and switching
they're like yes it's endemic yes we're
gonna have to learn to live with the
virus but no one should ever get it good
luck with that dude
would there be any public health benefit
to furthering it spread by lifting
travel restrictions for example so it
can out compete the delta variant you're
talking about something really dangerous
you're talking about let a lot of people
get infected to see if in fact you could
protect them that's something that i
think almost all infectious disease
people with any knowledge about
infectious disease would not say that's
a good idea
um so i'm just wondering why he says
that
is he is he challenging the idea of
natural immunity is that what he's doing
right there because natural immunity is
a well-established epidemio
epidemiological fact in fact the data on
on delta suggests that a natural
immunity to delta is probably more
durable than vaccine immunity despite
the cdc's proudest stations to the
contrary their israeli studies
demonstrating that that's probably not
true uh the the cdc's proto-stations
that is
so anthony fauci says are you suggesting
that we let people get sick to get
natural immunity no i'm suggesting you
have no ability to stop the spread of
disease that everything you have
attempted to do has been a giant failure
including the mass mandates in the
lockdowns
and so you're going to have to choose
how you wish to live with this
but fauci is just a bag of mixed
messages why the white house continues
to trot out this person who has lost all
public trust is beyond me
at what point does the booster
become part of the mandate yeah i can't
answer that right now but i know that
for the time being the official
definition of fully vaccinated is two
but do you see that changing we keep
having these variants we're concerned
about that it could change it could
change it could change yes
well i don't know let's see what what
rolls out now i mean i know if i say
it's gonna change it's gonna get spread
out that that's it we don't know right
now whether it should change but it
might
it might change it might not but it
might change but it also might not but
it might change again they have no
approach here they're just pretending
they have an approach
and by the way again
there's no evidence that the vaccines
are not standing up to this thing at
least in terms of hospitalization and
death which is the only thing i care
about i'm not gonna i'm gonna keep
repeating this until people get it
through their thick skulls it does not
matter if you get omicron if you don't
get that sick i don't understand why
this is remotely controversial
all three of my kids had colds this week
they're all fine because this is called
living as a human being on planet earth
people get sick as long as they're not
threatened with serious conditions or
death who gives a crap
even the biden administration used to
used to say this now apparently that
they just can't make up their minds and
again the fact that they can't make up
their minds underscores what i have been
saying now for months
for for more than a year at this point
people who refuse to acknowledge that
government cannot solve all of their
problems are the same people who believe
that we have to keep locking down we
have to keep being scared because after
all if they ever admit that government
can't solve all of our problems we might
actually start taking our lives into our
own hands and that wouldn't that be a
disaster wouldn't that be a disaster
here's a top research scientist on ms on
cnbc saying yeah by the way uh it looks
kind of like the vaccines are durable
against omicron and you're all panicking
because you're stupid
t-cells are what's really protecting us
from severe disease from covert
pneumonia and our t cells are very
insensitive not affected by variants
to any significant degree
so
there's lots of reasons for optimism
that this is not you know some uh
horrible situation that we're in the
vaccine should hold up against severe
disease especially with people who are
boosted
okay so what are we panicking over
exactly what exactly are we panicking
over okay so the the answer is again it
goes to the root baseline belief of
democrats of many people on the left
that they are capable of fixing your
life if you give them control this is
true in economics it's true in social
life it is true when it comes to disease
ron claine put out the most insane tweet
of the day yesterday so this is the
actual chief of staff of the white house
ron clayne is the shadow president
because joe biden is no longer with us
he sadly departed this earth at least on
a mental level i mean if we're talking
about viability i'm not sure that joe
biden is viable at this point as a human
joe biden left us many many months ago
ronald klein is the guy who's actually
making policy at the white house
so there's a columnist named greg ip who
writes the wall street journal and he
says kovid carved a partisan divide
through the united states democrats have
been much more cautious and protective
which manifests itself as generally
lower infections and deaths but also
much weaker economic outcomes omicron
could perpetuate that
okay so
here's the thing it sort of depends on
the state as far as as death per million
ratio because new york did worse than
than florida and uh new york is about
the same size as florida florida is much
more open but focus in on the economic
statement right there right where he's
correct about this that they are killing
their own economies ron claims we tell
quote nope
stronger coveted measures produce
stronger economic outcomes that's why
jobs growth and economic activity are up
this year significantly over last year
so insane that he says this it's almost
difficult to know where exactly to begin
it's like really
strong and covered measures produce
stronger economic outcomes which is why
we're up this year no we're up this year
because people got vaccinated and they
went back to work that's why we're up
this year your own president says this
but he's saying that it's stronger
coveted measures like lockdowns
presumably and mass mandates that
generate stronger economic if that's the
case why wasn't strong economic growth
the thing last year
after all we actually locked in our
houses for months at a time last year
we masked mandate i was living in
california last year and let me tell you
that place was like that place was
locked down tighter in tech
and economic growth was completely
stagnant it destroyed the economy of the
state
so ronald claim is just crazy stronger
coveted measures produce stronger
economic outcomes again just get rid of
covid there
and um and and the word stronger
economic and
bottom line is
that sentence without any of those
signifiers would read stronger measures
produce stronger outcomes that is the
democratic party platform in a nutshell
stronger measures produce stronger
outcomes
more regulation more top-down control
produces stronger outcomes now it's a
lie it's been a lie it was lie in the
soviet union with regards to the economy
and it's a lie with regards to kovid and
the economy
and by the way when i say it's a lie i
don't mean that he's just getting it
wrong i mean he is a liar because this
is perfectly available data
patrick raffini
who is a republican pollster he put out
a chart showing
the percent of jobs recovered since the
beginning of the pandemic by state
okay here are
the top states in terms of percentage of
jobs that have returned since the
beginning of the pandemic
utah idaho arizona texas montana south
dakota georgia nebraska tennessee south
carolina florida mississippi alabama
arkansas north carolina
not a blue state among them
the blue the only state that i just
listed that has a blue governor is north
carolina
which again is a state that tends to go
red in presidential elections
so every single state i just mentioned
in terms of jobs
recovered percentage of jobs recovered
is a red state
every single one
but you have ronald klein saying that no
lockdown measures are actually helpful
to the economy
okay fine so if you believe that why not
just lock it all back down
now the answer is the markets think that
that's what these guys believe this is
why the the dow is just getting
destroyed okay so the dow finished 460
points lower
on tuesday
according to the cnbc the major averages
fell sharply giving up solid gains on
wednesday after the cdc and prevention
confirmed the first case of oh
macron in the us markets are not afraid
of omicron markets are afraid of these
insane idiotic
public health officials locking down you
again that is what markets are afraid of
and they should be afraid of that
because these morons have run the
economy into the ground in what should
be the middle of the easiest recovery in
american history
because the economy was put into an
artificial coma last year and then
vaccines came and we were all supposed
to be like ready to go and now they're
talking about how stronger coveted
measures produce stronger economic
outcomes
it's no wonder that joe biden is down in
the high 30s low 40s in terms of public
approval rating meanwhile he's just out
there babbling nonsensically to himself
about economic matters he said yesterday
that he built the economic recovery no
you have stagnated an economic recovery
that was perfectly natural
and this guy is the the biggest
placebo effect when it comes to the
economy in american history except it
turns out that the placebo wasn't a
placebo he may be killing the patient
here is here's joe biden
we're seeing more new small businesses
higher wages and more disposable income
fewer children in poverty fewer people
getting unemployment checks none of this
was inevitable it was because of the
american rescue plan
which virtually every democrat in
congress voted for and every republican
voted against
it was because of the hard work my
administration has done to try to solve
the challenges in our economy instead of
just pointing fingers and complaining
nope you did not build the economic
recovery your economic recovery has been
rife with inflation which was completely
unnecessary because you decided to pay
people to stay home so in under supply
of labor we have supply chain shortages
and you blew money into the economy we
didn't need to do that we didn't need to
do it you did that what you built here
is the failure of the economy meanwhile
joe biden is still babbling to himself
about how his plan to battle inflation
is working really is it is it really
working so well here is joe biden saying
something completely nonsensical as is
his want
prices are still out of sunk
excuse me prices are still out of sync
as the world comes back
but as we continue to overcome these
obstacles
the more price pressures will ease
but i have not been content to sit back
and wait
i've used every tool available to
address the price increases
and it's working
really i is it working now because um
i'm uh because
actually jerome powell came out
yesterday and he said that inflation is
no longer transitory so is it is it
working particularly well joe is it
meanwhile joe biden is still promoting
more spending more spending build back
better is going to fix everything now my
republican friends are talking a lot
about prices
but they're lined up against my
buildback better plan which would go
right at the problem for rising costs
for families
why is that
i don't want to speculate on anyone's
motive
but it's always easier to complain about
the problem than to try to fix it
oh really um i noticed that that's all
you do is complain about problems that
you yourself created
and uh and that you do nothing about
while your secretary of transportation
is on a two-month paternity leave
in the middle of supply chain crisis
meanwhile janet yellen saying the same
thing she's just lying also so janet
yellen again these are all political
hacks whenever you see
the notion that there is a non-partisan
branch of the government
that is filled with political appointees
just remember secretary yellen was the
head of the federal reserve until five
minutes ago a non-partisan political
figure and here she is now just openly
lying about buildback better not adding
to deficits it's not true according to
the cbo
these investments we expect will lead to
a gdp increase over the long term
without increasing the national debt or
deficit by a dollar
in fact the offsets in these bills mean
they actually reduce annual deficits
over time
okay so um yeah sure we believe you we
believe you the spider administration by
the way
finally you and at root the biden
administration they're just control
freaks and angry old people shouting at
clouds so here here's an angry old man
shouting at a cloud he's very angry that
people are noticing that they're not
being that they're not able to uh
gain um
products during the christmas season
here's joe biden shouting at people for
noticing that their milk is more
expensive
if you watch the news recently you might
think the shelves in all our stores are
empty across the country
that parents won't be able to get
presents for their children on holidays
this holiday season
but here's the deal
for the vast majority of the country
that's not what's happening
because of the actions the
administration has taken in partnership
with business and labor
retailers and grocery stores freight
movers and railroads and those shelves
are going to be stocked
oh are they uh because that's not what
i'm hearing from all of the people who
are in industry right now
but it's you the people who are at fault
these your great rulers will be the ones
who eventually decide whether you are
allowed to have liberty or not so i
guess the leftist notion of governance
can be summed up in uh in the following
logic you have the right to decide your
meaning of the universe of life of human
existence when it comes to killing
babies in your womb but when it comes to
your ability to actually live your life
freely we will tell you when you're
allowed to live your life freely at
least when you're not killing babies you
can kill babies that's the deal you can
kill as many babies as you want but can
you go to work today without a mask
well no that we will control
if this is the kind of governance you
look forward to keep voting blue
seriously and stay the hell out of my
state please
all right we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime go check out our newest
podcast morning wire on today's episode
they discuss joe biden's vax mandates
having setbacks in court that episode is
available right now on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts make
sure to tune in i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily dailywire2021
john bickley here daley wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our new show morning wire on
today's episode president biden's
vaccine mandates suffer several court
setbacks the supreme court hears
arguments on a landmark abortion case
and cnn suspends host chris cuomo
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire